bonsoir antoine vous étiez donc sur
place et vous avez suivi l'intégralité
de cette conférence de presse que
peut-on retenir
oui bonsoir stéphanie l'exercice de
cette année aura duré 4h30 une
conférence de presse lors de laquelle de
très nombreux sujets ont été évoqués
avec en premier lieu bien entendu cette
pandémie de kovy 19 n'a été question du
système de santé russes et de sa
capacité à s'adapter à cette crise de
l'impact de cette crise sanitaire sur
l'économie ou encore des vaccins
développés par la russie à ce propos un
journaliste a même posé la question
suivante à vladimir poutine
monsieur le président allez-vous vous
faire vacciner
voici sa réponse les vaccins qui sont en
circulation
la population sont destinés à une
certaine catégorie d'âge et pour
l'instant les gens comme moi ne sont pas
encore concernés par cette catégorie jeu
mais je respecte la loi je suis les
recommandations de nos spécialistes est
pour l'instant moi je me suis fais pas
je me suis pas fait vacciner mais je le
ferai dès que ce sera possible de cette
pandémie
vladimir poutine a au passage souhaité
un prompt rétablissement emmanuel macron
en marge de cette conférence de presse
mais de nombreux thèmes de l'actualité
internationale ont aussi été abordés on
peut citer par exemple les situations
dans le haut-karabagh en ukraine ou
encore en biélorussie vladimir poutine a
également dit vouloir améliorer les
relations entre la russie et les etats
unis avec l'arrivée de joe biden à la
maison blanche notamment via le
renouvellement du traité new start de
réduction des armes stratégiques
la sphère navalni a elle aussi été
évoquée avec les dernières accusations
de médias occidentaux qui mettent en
cause des agents du fsb propose
d'écouter la réponse de vladimir poutine
sur ce sujet
dire que ce patient de la clinique
bernoise
il bénéficie de l'appui des services
secrets américains concrètement alors
c'est intéressant droit ça veut dire
effectivement que les services secrets
doivent suivre cette affaire de près
vous comprenez alors je l'enquêté
peut-être peut-être pas achevé faut la
poursuivre son épouse a demandé à
pouvoir le suivre en allemagne chez
donné l'autorisation d'état étranger
avec qui ils apprécient négocier
échangés le président russe a donné de
nom le dirigeant chinois xi jinping avec
qui il dit entretenir une relation
d'amitié et le président turc recep
tayyip erdogan
chez qu'il apprécie le franc parler il
est vrai que les deux hommes poutine et
erdogan s'oppose sur de nombreux
dossiers mais arrive toujours à
communiquer à s'entendre
de façon concrète c'est ainsi que s'est
terminée cette conférence de presse au
format inhabituel certes mais qui aura
permis à vladimir poutine de s'exprimer
sur de très nombreux sujets merci
antoine claireaux depuis moscou